well
waters released the
real estate report for the month of november
how are you greetings cristian cásseres the
average price of a single family home
is around 420 thousand dollars
this is an estimated 21 percent more
compared to the previous year the
condominiums also surpassed the figures
of a year ago since they are at an
average price of 240 thousand dollars the
fexf Reuters believe that prices
will continue to rise slowly in the
coming months while
interest rates also rise and that is why
the state of nevada  will host a
massive job fair this will be
today where thousands of jobs
will be offered to the chaves community it
will take place at the
las vegas convention center from
9am to 2pm the
parking lot is completely
free doctor jesus jara announced
that he will be created as superintendent of
the court county school district now
the unions will be debating  Talking about
cob and mandatory vaccines it has been
three months since the
school board approved this mandate
however this could have an impact
on over 40,000 employees
unions believe students
should be involved in this
discussion once the  district and
union come to an agreement it will be
presented to the board of directors for an
evaluation and we move on to the weather forecast
as we can see
we will be in the 60s for the whole
week with some chance of
rain for Thursday we will continue with
partly cloudy skies and  The
temperatures will drop for the
weekend I'm Cristian Cáceres with the
Kirchner news bulletin in Spanish Good
day
[Music]